i want us to think about this situation
okay
but let's try and use the tools that we
have in terms of mathematics to do this
okay
so draw yourself up a set of axes
just give me the first quadrant you'll
see why in a second
what i want us to imagine is this ball
and the measurements we took over time
okay now because i was throwing the ball
up and down i want to think about this
displacement in up and down terms
so i'm going to call this axis here the
x-axis
you know how when you learn chord
geometry for the first time in the
cartesian plane
um you're like it's always x and y do we
always really need to
label the axes and your math teachers
always said yes
yes you must label the axes yes we want
to dark marks
part of the big reason why is directly
to lead up to this
okay for motion it's absolutely
essential that you have your axis level
so you know what you're talking about
okay so there's our x our displacement
what i'm going to do horizontally here
right is not that the ball is moving
horizontally
but i'm thinking about the ball at
different points in time
okay so i've got a displacement axis
and a time axis okay time zero
that's when you hit go on your stopwatch
okay so where was the ball at that time
now i suppose you could say i was
holding it here and that's like
i don't know like 1.3 meters off the
ground or something like that
okay so i suppose you could call it
we started at 1.3 okay but being that it
started there
and at least i tried to end there as
well
right we might as well call this the
origin
i'll make it the origin okay so
therefore at time zero
i'm at zero okay
now um it took some number of seconds
and it went through the air eventually
it came back down and i caught it right
so we're going to come back down to the
axis like so
and um what was the um what was the
longest one when i threw it further in
the air what was the time measured for
how long was in the air
like three seconds something like that
two two
i'm going to call it four just for the
simplicity of numbers
okay just as an example okay
now we want to consider this in terms of
maths
right so right now we've entered an
imagined world
for that reason i'm ignoring all kinds
of things that
make the situation more complicated okay
so i know that the ball was somewhere up
in the air now when i took all of your
numbers
right it was pretty close to between
halfway in between it wasn't exactly
but there were lots of problems with
that like people who said
you know this was two this was two and
this was 0.6 or something like that okay
so therefore i'm just gonna simplify a
little bit and call it
halfway at time two we're up in the air
now
where would you guess that we stopped
what did it feel like what did it look
like
five meters six meters
i'm i'm i'm 1.78 or something like that
it went at least three times higher than
my height right like if it's here
so i'm going to call it i'm going to
call it six
now you told me you told me that up here
is when it sort of stopped for a brief
moment in time okay now what would that
look like
well in terms of graphs we call these
points we have names for them
right we call them stationary points
because guess what
at that moment in time
which is a moment it really is just a
moment the ball
is stationary it's not going anywhere
it's not going up and it's not going
down it's just
floating there for a split second right
that's why it's called
a stationary point right and then what
happens to either side well you've got
to come back down to the axis
does it come down
like this why not
okay you told me the speed changed right
now remember
this is a linear function right the
thing about linear functions is that
they don't change speed
it's going at a constant rate all along
the way and you know that because dx and
dt for that guy
is a constant so we have to ditch this
guy
instead to account for the fact that
it's slowed down we're getting this kind
of [ __ ]
okay now
you also said that as it came back down
right it was going fastest
as i caught it right so therefore this
speed is doing the same thing on this
side as it was doing over here
right it's coming down and it lands
okay now quick question what happened
as time went five six seven eight what
was happening
to the ball
was it doing this
it wasn't was it okay um even though you
know actually i didn't drop the ball did
i i don't think i ever dropped it
so it was always it never got any lower
than the origin
my hand okay now this is where this
graph
right which you are very familiar with
its shape this is where it goes but it's
not where the ball goes
right and the same way you know i don't
have any like what was the ball doing
before
it was just in my hand at the origin
okay so therefore
we need to say this thing is restricted
don't you love restrictions i know you
love restrictions
we've got a time restriction don't we
right
zero to four
there's my time restriction okay
now this is a very very simple shape
it's very simple
luckily for you it actually is exactly
what it looks like
okay um which is a parabola okay
so we know how to describe parabolas
just like in exponential growth and
decay
we observe something and we think about
the mathematical things we know that fit
the pattern
right a parabola fits this okay so what
kind of parabola would it be well it has
roots at
zero and four doesn't it right so you
automatically know
what kind of form is it going to be in x
equals what
if zero and four are roots as it were
right it should be t outside of
t minus four that's got roots at zero
and four doesn't it
so i know that the problem with this guy
though
is that um he doesn't match this does it
right
why what's wrong with this
this this is concave
up isn't it this looks like this right
you know because it's got a t-squared
there
but my ball is not an anti-gravity ball
so what should i do to adjust it
i should flip it upside down now
that's not all does this account for
what i've got let's try something
let's try time equals zero does it work
it does
time equals four does it work it does
and that's that's because we accounted
for that when we made up the equation
right
ah but time equals two what happens when
time equals two
you get x equals minus two
times two minus four which is also minus
two
you get four that's not as high as i
want to go
is it so how do i change it
you got a couple of choices don't you
you could say i'm at 4 but i want to be
at 6.
so you could just add 2
to everything that would get you six
right but there's a problem with doing
that
what's the problem
it fixes this point but then it marks up
these guys because they won't be
at zero anymore will then they'll be
moved up like the rest of it okay
so i abandoned i abandoned this idea of
adding a constant
what else could i do
i could multiply now multiplying is a
better idea one of the ways you can see
that apart from guesswork
is that if i think about this one that
i've fashioned all right
what would it look like in relation to
what i plotted well
four is four is there
right i know exactly what this looks
like it looks like this
all right now what's that this is
another way you could have known that
just adding a constant would not give
you the shape that you wanted right
in fact what i want is a stretching out
of the same shape that i guessed
okay so that's why i should multiply it
by what factor
three and two one and a half right
because um six is
one and a half lots of four okay so
that's what i'm going to do
there you go does it match does it match
it looks like it matches all of the
points and the general kind of curvature
right let's push on this a little
further let's explore it
this is just displacement here okay
so here's the magic of maths right you
don't need to do any guesswork or rely
on observation
you can rely on maths that you know for
certain and is precise
what is the x on detail shall i expand
this maybe that'll make it a little
easier
this is negative 3 over 2 t squared
plus 6
yeah 16. there we go
we've got the double negative great okay
so what's the derivative
negative three t plus six that looks
like correct
okay now does this match why don't we
graph this
then rather than looking at them at
specific points in time we can consider
the whole thing
okay so i'm going to get a new set of
axes because i don't want to confuse it
too much with this
um negative 3t plus 6 what does it look
like
well you've got a y-intercept
of six oh i was naughty what did i miss
axes thank you okay this is another
reason why
you've got to be careful with because
you're going to frequently get graphing
the velocity and graphing the
acceleration
so this is velocity against time
so i've got my six what's happening to
the rest of the graph where's it going
it's dropping like a rock
okay now what's this intercept over here
it's um it's two right wait a second
my graph keeps going this thing keeps on
going all the way up to four right so in
fact this this graph needs to go as well
the domain restriction that applied over
there
should be the same as here right so in
fact
if that's two then four must be around
here
i'm going to keep going all the way over
like so
okay so i really should put these filled
end points here to indicate the graph
stops right because that's the only
place it's defined
so does this match does it match
let's think about it shall we at the
start
what was the velocity well it was
positive what does that correspond to
what was the ball doing
it was moving upward right moving
upwards okay
so that makes sense as the ball got
closer to time two
which is where it stopped the ball was
slowing down
it was still moving up but it was
slowing down okay
so far so good what's happening over
here
the ball drops it starts to return to my
hand
okay now at what point does it actually
stop
or should i say what velocity is it what
is
the x dx on dt intercept that
corresponds to time
four well it's going to be minus times 4
which is negative 12
plus 6 it's negative 6.
now what this model predicts is that the
speed that i that it was going at when i
threw it
speed is the same speed as what it was
when it landed
okay now obviously if you say in terms
of velocity they're directly opposite
because one's up
and one is down okay does that match
if you throw a ball up harder does it
come back to you
faster
at lunch time you can go and experiment
right now we looked at displacement
we looked at velocity there's one last
piece isn't there
there's acceleration right so that is d
squared
x on d t squared
okay now again wearing your calculus hat
you know exactly what the acceleration's
equal what's
equal to it's just negative three
what does that mean
so the first thing is i don't feel the
need to graph this because
it's constant the acceleration is never
changing
right now this is one of the reasons why
the accelerating decelerating language
is a problem because when we talk about
this like if we forget that we're in
maths right
and think about is this accelerating or
decelerating i think we would normally
say
between 0 and 2. it's
decelerating because it's got it's
slowing down that's what you told me and
then we got there and it stopped moving
and then we would say after that it
starts accelerating
towards the ground until i catch it
right
but that doesn't that doesn't back up
this at all does it doesn't make sense
the language that we use either has
broken the model or the model has broken
the language
okay now being that we can see this is
all consistent and it made sense
okay i'm gonna go with the fact that
like english it's just
it's confusing and it doesn't it wasn't
designed to match mathematical reality
it was designed to
fit well normal language and everyday
use right which is not talking about
this
so we said it's constant
it's negative it's negative it's always
negative
why is that
what does this correspond to
acceleration is a bit tricky
it's related to but not the same as the
idea of a force
right that something is trying to slow
down
or speed up in a certain direction
there's something
this guy right which is constantly
constantly
no literally constantly changing this so
it's always decreasing that's what it's
doing
right uh what does it correspond to
what it corresponds to for us is gravity
right from
well not even the second i let go of the
ball right even while i'm holding the
ball
gravity is accelerating it downwards now
what's stopping it at the moment
is um the electrons in my hand and
i won't get into it okay but um
gravity is acting on it and it's always
acting on it right and it's still acting
on it when i release
it's acting on in exactly the same way
the whole time okay
now remember we made up all these
numbers we fashioned them all okay
but we can know that this whole model is
actually quite off i'll tell you how
what unit is our time access here
it's in seconds right
now we started presupposing that the
x-axis the displacement was in meters
because that's a normal sort of unit for
that
right meters meters okay
so it stands to reason therefore that
the displacement equation
gives us this in meters
because that's the unit of displacement
when you've got displacement and time
and time's being divided it's on the
bottom right you've got meters
per second
right yeah careful stay with me there's
one unit of um
length here right there's one unit of
length here how many units of length are
they're here
still one because the squared is not on
the x right it's on the
how many times you differentiate right
so this is still meters
how many time units are there here none
how many time units here
one how many time units here there are
two
or alternatively
okay because it's about a velocity
change per time
right if you want to think about it that
way okay um
just to confuse you further right you
know how i said x dot next double dot
right because it's velocity it just as
frequently gets called v
for velocity right which makes this a
for acceleration but it also means that
because acceleration is how velocity is
changing over time
it's dv on dt
that's paint isn't it people in their
notation it is convenient though
thankfully it's mostly self-explanatory
um now by the way that's why this often
gets written as meters per second to the
power of minus two
right like that's just index notation
here and this is the point at which i
know
all of our numbers were actually pretty
inaccurate right because what is gravity
it's not minus three meters per second
squared it's
it's closer to ten isn't it nine point
minus nine point eight if you're
thinking about
velocity okay so therefore if we wanted
to we could say
ah that's bogus because i know what that
is right so we can change this
and i can go back up instead of by
differentiating
i would integrate which you can do